servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute wird endlich mal
wieder jump league gespielt und ich saß
heute daran dachte mir okay wir wollen
viel für jump league spielen
was machen wir im video man dachte ich
mir dass wir die einfachste und
simpelste und trotzdem bricht aus neisse
challenge überhaupt nicht gemacht haben
und zwar die münzwurf challenge also
machen wir das heute wir werfen vor
jeder kiste einmal die münze die münze
entscheiden ob er sie aufmachen dürfen
oder nicht bezahlte sie öffnen bei kopf
habe ich meinen pop schutz und wir
dürfen sie nicht öffnen
zu dem zweck habe ich hier auch eine
münze können wir die kurzen blenden hier
und schaut euch mal diese konstruktion
an seht ihr das hier
ich habe hier mein iphone auf meine
kamera drauf gelegt die auf dem tripod
ist weil der akku meine kamera beim
aufnahme versuch gerade eben gestorben
ist deswegen muss man ein iphone jetzt
einspringen müssen wir loslegen leute
die anderen geben auch schon vollgas
hier kommt ganz schnell zack zack zack
zack zack und flott aber wie gestimmt
zuerst eine kiste wo ist die erste kiste
also wie schon bei 39 prozent sind aber
damit jobs sucht jeder runde
das alles klar
da müssen wir hier hoch scheint ja okay
jetzt werden wir die münze hier münzwurf
challenge letzte zahl wie gesagt dürfen
wir bei kopf nicht kopf mist wieder in
die kiste nicht aufmachen und flott
mutig zackig weiter wie die vorgelegten
schon bei frucht bei 40% wtf ok piste
nummer zwei wieder münzwurf zahl meist
wieder reinschauen und bamm bamm bamm
bamm moslems meist weil es nichts zu
berauben das war die vier gold können
wir brauchen vielleicht um gold apfel so
leute ich hab mir letztens mal meine
gefleckten comments durchgeschaut also
die kommentare die von youtube als spam
oder beleidigen markiert wurden
und ach du scheiße darauf muss ich
eingehen wir die kiste ausgelöst haben
so sah und kopf nein müsste müssen
weiter was da drin steht ein schwede und
die zwei wesentlichsten punkte die in
diesen flecken also genetik blocken
kommentaren drin stehen möchte ich heute
mal besprechen
punkt nummer eins spd schwenkt dich so
nein wie kommt man darauf dass ein
durchschnittlicher junger mann sich
schwingt ich verstehe es nicht okay aber
wir werfen die münze
und kopf schon wieder nicht fucking
heraldo dass wir das thema wirklich
ansprechen weil ich mich natürlich nicht
schminke obwohl extrem viele leute
glauben dass mich schminken als ich weiß
wie die leute drauf kommen ob es daran
liegt dass ich irgendwie glaube ich habe
von natur aus etwas längere und wimpern
dass er mal ein paar mädels gesagt dass
das so sei aber ansonsten ist es nicht
vielleicht auch komisch dass so ein
bisschen von oben drauf scheint deswegen
sieht es hier so aus die irgendwas an
den augen
kapiert nicht ganz aber das soll ich mal
ansprechen und nächste münze kopf
vogginger da schon wieder nicht so und
zack zack sein nächster großer punkt der
auch in den kommentaren bestellt ist
bist du schwul dazu nein auch das ist
nicht der fall
es gibt ein teilweise so schien es ist
die denn die seien so schreiben so okay
erhalten t shirt in regenbogenfarben
alter was im bundestag an und alten zopf
safe schule hundertprozentig es gibt
keine möglichkeit dass er nicht schwul
ist
dazu muss ich aber sagen leute nein ich
bin nicht schwul auch das hat überhaupt
nichts auf youtube zu suchen eigentlich
so was aber die diese kommentare suchst
du stupide dass man einfach darauf
eingehen muss okay hier alles klar
nächster münzwurf und es ist eine zahl
wieder verein sehr schön sagt zack zack
zack zack so pam pam das modul 7 relativ
tricky aber habt ihr gesehen wie die am
anfang davon gezogen sind wir haben
jetzt alle ziemlich gut eingeholt damit
auf platz zwei verbessert ein paar tage
ist wieder nicht amtlich gespielt da
kommt schon relativ schnell wieder aus
der übung raus und da unten ist die
nächste kiste münzwurf 3 2 und ist ein
zahlt er wieder voran und sehr schön
sehr schön wichtig eine waffe sind bis
jetzt gar nicht aufgefallen wären
bisschen und so eine hässliche holz axt
wir werden natürlich konsequent
durchziehen mit der kisten change und
auch die kisten in deathmatch nur
eröffnen okay jetzt hat es gereicht wenn
wir entsprechend vormunds glück hatten
so okay jetzt mal bei dem hier lies gut
nächstes modul das habe ich auch nie
hinbekommen sich einfach diesen sind
trick raus gefunden habe der trick ist
eigentlich also hier double jumper auf
das cockpit und dann hier einfach
bisschen glück haben teilweise kommt man
das ding dann an die leiter teilweise
nicht muss einfach nur ein bisschen
schräg davon absprechen
gefühl dann ist es wenn du eigentlich
super super easy so erstmal hier nächste
kiste nächster münzwurf und werden
eingeholt
jawohl es in zwei wir dürfen ran und
nice alles sehr schön wenn es einmal
umziehen hier ganz flott auf dem gang
öffentliche nacktheit ist ist eigentlich
verbotene deutschland aber wer weiß wo
die jumping server stehen wahrscheinlich
nicht in deutschland sondern in irland
oder so
dementsprechend gilt irisches gesetz und
what the [ __ ] die nächste kiste nächsten
münzwurf ja bezahlt wir dürfen ran und
ness ein kleiner stein shot sehr wichtig
mir was einem wichtig leute dass man so
eine kleine münze eingebaut haben
just for fun einfach weil es cool
aussieht haben jetzt diese kleine minsk
m
so jetzt auch mal flüssig durch hier
wollen und die letzte kiste wird uns das
glück hold sein und schnell schnell in
der grafischen mein kopf wir dürfen
nicht ran
und jetzt konzentriert 13 sekunden auf
es wird wahrscheinlich nicht von 23
reichen aber wenn es ich schaffen können
wir es theoretisch ins ziel schaffen
nice wunderbar gg der mediabus und das
death match beginnt leute alles klar
hinten runter
leute das ziel ist heute natürlich auch
wie immer wie in jeder anderen challenge
versuchen die runde zu gewinnen
und da ist unser erstes opfer franz 2000
oder 3000 3000 franz 3000 leute ist es
ist der echte als ob man jetzt so
eiskalt abstaubte sack hatte dafür
kriegt halt so diverse kommunen ein
alter kommen noch drei andere der ems
anbieter der die wollte ich jetzt
unbedingt haben dass es passiert ist wie
wollen sie wieder abstauben
so was hab ich immer so einmal ab
gestoppt werden einmal abstauben dass
der kreislauf ist abgegeben muss aber
bis auf die balance achten ok piste ist
da nun zu werfen dürfen
kopf wir dürfen nicht reinschauen alles
klar die nächsten gegner
trotzdem ganz wichtig what the [ __ ] wie
hertie hat er uns jetzt geholt man
kräftig dafür werden immer besser jetzt
gegeben
ok scheinbar nicht wo ich habe nur noch
ein lebender ich dachte werden jetzt ein
gutes equipment aber so dass jetzt schon
mal ziemlich schnell drauf gegangen
einmal mehr was soll man sagen
drei gegner hier wurden abgestaubt beim
anderen mal hatten es der typ jetzt doch
schauen wir die besseren hits gegeben
dass ich bisschen überrascht er ich
gesagt jetzt abschreiben oder ihn
abstauben ok alles klar sehr schön gut
wichtig sei aber man sollte auch nicht
zu sehr abstauben deutlich sagte doping
immer wissen die balance halten
jetzt habe ich einen abstauber zu viel
auf dem konto theoretisch würde das
heißt dass wir gleich noch abgestimmt
werden müssen aber sowas macht einfach
hier risky mlg dann passt das auch da
wohl alles klar damit wir unseren
abstand punkt wieder gut gemacht wie ein
bisschen kammer gesammelt und jetzt
können davon ein wenig ist zu schauen
und zu werfen
ja ein zweiter verein schon wieder
reinschauen und okay was ist da nicht
viel sparen dass eigentlich da egal
kommen fasst dafür schnell davon rein ob
beide brennen das ist gut dass gerade da
kommt natürlich gerne rein und kann sie
den hunger so kickl
jawoll jetzt werden wir in münster
bendix rhein schon dürfen
und zack 1 ja mal wieder vorbeischauen
zahl ist ja wohl fns das kümmern noch
gebrauchen
viertes gold mitnehmen müssen gold und
äpfel zu spät gesehen so ok alles klar
jetzt habe ich unsere letzten gegner und
ich würde sagen den holen wir uns mal
sei es ja wohl
jawoll dame in sie sehr schön wunderbar
leute eine sache wohl ich noch
ansprechen komme jetzt bisschen spät
aber wir sind letzter zeit aufgefallen
dass die discs ziemlich zugenommen haben
unter den videos und ich freue mich
persönlich ob sich mein content
verschlechtert hat ich bin nämlich immer
damit der meinung dass man sich nicht
mit anderen vergleichen sollte aber wohl
mit sich selbst und ich die vorstellung
hat nicht mag dass ich meinen content
vergleich zum letzten monat oder so
verschlechtert hat deswegen man
irgendwas habt was euch jetzt weniger
gefällt als im letzten monat kam mehr
krieg bald titel wurde war schlechtere
ideen schreibt das bitte in die
kommentare
damit ich mir das anschauen kann daran
arbeiten kann und bessere videos für
euch machen kann
ok dankeschön dafür und dann bis zum
nächsten video drei macht's gut minsk
mrd und ja